you can tell everybody about brett
anderson okedokey i hope the royals
hitters find out more about him if as he
elevates
in today's ballgame we hope
he gets a lot of ground balls and that
one's in the center field for a game
opening single
then cedric mullins for the american
league lead and
he's gonna anderson's gonna be called
for a box so
it looked like whit and rusty koontz had
picked up on something and whit was
gonna take off and then anderson did
something unexpected get him over
and he does
and even better than that
whit rounds third and holds so santana
just trying to do the team thing
and getting marifield to third instead
puts runners at first and third and
nobody out do they want to concentrate
on getting that run across for minor
that'll work center field deep taylor is
back and he'll make the play on the
track so merrifield comes down from
third
and the
scoreless inning streak comes to an end
and the royals lead one nothing in the
first
and
here's the royals 33 year old
left-hander mike miner
and that's driven to the gap and ben and
tendy with the slice is able to come
over and make the play
the pitch
in there slider called strike three that
was right down the heart of the plate
good break
by mike miner's
slider
and he is down on strikes
so miner gets a nice defensive play by
ben and tendi and then strikes out
adamus and yelich
all right mike miner for amazing garcia
that one's out of bounds omni was not
running and he's still going to beat it
out
that was a very strange play garcia
thought he was going to be caught
and he ends up beating it down the line
and i think santana as well thought it
was going to be caught he was playing
well off the bag with the shift and he
became a spectator as well expecting
meritfield to make this catch 3-2
delivery and you can't do nothing high
and wide he walked him and the brewers
have to on
here he comes ryus bounces to third and
bobbled
picked up by lopez going to be safe all
around
they've got him loaded now for casting
hiro and the brewers will gladly take it
base is loaded down nobody out
here
hits it into
shallow center field taylor makes the
grab garcia tags and holds
here's manny pina the catcher
and pete runs one to left field a base
hit garcia scores taylor right behind
him he will score
it's a two rbi single for the pineapple
and the brewers have the lead little
fastball or change-up just leaked back
over the plate and allowed manny to get
good wood to it
gets a puck down that's a beauty perez
has one play
the gold glover makes the play
can't do it any better than that brad
anderson with a sacrifice pump
and pull to the right side
and the out is made brett anderson
quickly back to work the pitch
and a swing
my ball get pretty deep to center
sending taylor back looking up and it's
gone
a home run for jorge solaire to straight
away center field and that ties the game
2-2
yeah you know when he bows up at the
plate like that after making contact
i can usually will tell you that he got
all that one breaking ball he waited for
it and you can see where it hit the
barrel perfect swing got up underneath
it
got a little lift
and he watched it
so back to work mike miner in his first
pitch
is popped up on the infield off the bat
of luis urias and it is caught by the
third baseman coming in hunter dozier
up the middle nikki lopez cuts it off
that is not an easy throw but it's on
target
and there are two down
it's a good pitch kept the ball down
and miner has a one two three bottom of
the fourth after the royals tie the game
got a good one going today at american
family field it is 2-2 as we head to the
bottom of the sixth inning
ami garcia first ball swinging into the
gap left center
and a nice play in center field by
taylor that's gonna hold garcia to a
single
ready for a one and two
and there goes garcia the pitch is
called a strike throw to second is late
so it's a strikeout garcia able to keep
a foot on the bag
strike out at a stolen base it's the
second out of the inning royals are
going to challenge this
and
by applying the tag and holding the tag
on the leg which
we've seen more and more of the past few
years because all it takes is for the
foot to become
disengaged for an inch
so there's whit keeping the tag on
and are the spikes off the bag right
there
[Music]
and he's out strike him out throw him
out so that will end the inning
here we are in the seventh inning
chop to the left side that is a fair
ball
now taylor didn't see it immediately he
was thinking about beating out a ground
ball so he ran through first
and isn't able to
turn that into a double but
it's not really a bad play by urias i
don't think he could have gotten taylor
if he feeled it so he took the gamble
mickey
hits it into left center field
and yelich will make the play
taylor tags he's on his way to second
and he's going to be in there
it's a big opportunity for o'hern right
here you get your one at bat a game keep
your focus here be ready
and ryan drills one to center field
taylor is back and ryan o'hearn
hits his third career
pinch hit home run
and the royals lead 4-2 in the seventh
inning ding-ding-ding
what a beauty
talking about the backdoor slider he was
waiting for a fastball
and hunter strickland gave it to him
right there belt high great swing under
control look at that bottle it up
turn and burn o'hern
that was sweet what a pickup jake brent
comes on in the bottom of the seventh
with a two-run lead
here broke his back little flare that is
gonna fall
a base hit for hiro you'll take it
[Applause]
in the air center field little flare
that one's gonna fall
all these rockets off the bats of the
brewers
long he muscles one left field that's
going to get down
a base hit pina scrambles to second
three flares and the bores have it
loaded up here with one away in the
seventh
and kyle zimmer on the mound the
right-hander to face willie adams how
about a double play ball keep the ball
down fastball slatter change curve
there you go there's the ground ball
nikki lopez to merrifield and high but
santana keeps his foot on the bag
[Applause]
off the bag
and
down there on the back
and a baby roll them up
two innings to go k.c leading four to
two and now salvador perez will lead
things up
he lines it up the left field line
that's fair and down into the corner
[Applause]
and the royals have a runner at second
base with nobody out in the eighth
and that's what he's trying to do he's
going to get it down race to the base
and sanchez is just
a half a step ahead of ben and tendy
that'll get salvi to third so the bases
are loaded with one out and key walks by
dozier and solaire
taylor gets on a high fastball and
drives it into center field that'll get
one home everybody's tagging the throw
will go to third
and it'll be cut off
so the royals
take a 5-2 lead on the sacrifice fly
salvi scores dozier goes to third
greg holland is on for his sixth save
royals by the way
have lost 12 in a row on the road
[Music]
and a fastball is right by him
so one out
and 500 strikeouts as a royal for greg
holland
fastball is hit high and deep to left
field ben and tendy is at the wall and
he's got it
he said no i am here
had plenty of time to get underneath it
didn't rob it
took away an extra base
the pitch
swung on and missed he struck him out
ball game over the royals win it 5-2
the hero of the ball game ryan o'hearn
with his two-run home run that broke the
2-2 tie